he's staring me down here you probably
noticed your backyard a little more
active right now with spring pass
depending where you live you may have
crickets ants roaches even scorpions
mary jane belly as i share some ways to
prevent scorpions from coming into your
home
we found them in our bathroom
in the hallway you know coming in off
the door so that's why we put some traps
around those areas mary randina is
trying to fix the scorpion problem she
has at her summerlin home thankfully
nobody's ever gotten stung we found them
i've screamed loudly and my husband
comes running and gets rid of them mike
holly from red rock pest control says
she's not the only one calls are
starting to pour in as scorpions come
out of hiding it is getting warmer so
now they'll come out during the day and
they'll be on block walls or whatever
but then as it gets colder we will drop
below that 75 degrees at night and then
they're going to find places so if
they're caught next to a house they're
going to try to go inside of a home ali
says scorpions like to stay in cool and
dark places making a pile of leaves like
this the perfect hiding spot if you have
stuff stacked up like wood piles or you
have blocks some people have extra roof
tiles stacked up those are perfect i
mean those are those are mega resorts
for them and while a scorpion sting may
last for a few days fatalities remain
low he says there are a few ways to keep
scorpions at bay like sealing your
weather stripping keeping vegetation
away and keeping your home clutter free
it's a matter of just inspecting or
regularly brushing your your animals and
keeping them taken care of the kids
watching the toys and the stuff that you
drag in from outside leaving doors open
and if you have insects indoors if
you're noticing insects getting that
taken care of because that's what
they're looking for they're looking for
a food source mary jane baleza live
local now